la scène est fictive mais en réalité
elle existe un aîné est exclue d'une
partie de cartes
tenue à l'écart comme toujours les sites
ne donnera pas de la roya monuc a tenu
une autre est victime de commentaires
désobligeants avec des cas classique
d'intimidation chez les aînés
la professeure de l'université de
sherbrooke marie beaulieu étudie ce
phénomène encore peu documenté
particulièrement des loisirs qui peuvent
être un peu compétitif donc les jeux
pétanque par exemple où on veut gagner
le jeu de bridge où on souhaite bonne
soeur m'a initié quelqu'un qui moins
rapides que nous de plus en plus d'aînés
victime d'intimidation contacter
l'association québécoise de défense des
droits des personnes retraitées et
préretraitées c'est très fréquent il y
en a un moment donné qui nous appellent
puis nous parlent de leur situation et
dispos qu'ils sont intimidés et
d'esquiver dit certaines choses avec
d'autres personnes mais on décode
facilement que c'est l'intimidation
c'est malheureux parce que ça que tu
étais comme trahi dans ton intégrité
le problème est tel que l'association a
senti le besoin de donner des
conférences de sensibilisation aux aînés
l'intimidation demeure méconnu est à
bout des gens on se retrouve en parler
seuls les plus gros le gros barbecue
c'est khayari nice muséum d'art quand
vous aimons dénonce cours il s'envole de
postes mais pourtant les conséquences
chez les victimes peuvent être graves
dame avait été intimidée elle était
stigmatisé le wave y vivent ça amenait
un déménagement déjà un moment donné qui
sort plus que des gens qui osent pu
s'exprimer que déjà que 5 malanda parce
que samba et sans trop vieux les sales
gosses les conséquences les plus graves
de l'intimidation c'est vraiment
l'isolément social et plus les gens
s'isole plus on sait que le risque de
mortalité de vie important pour contrer
l'intimidation l'association québécoise
de défense des droits des personnes
retraitées et préretraitées encourage
les aînés à s'affirmer et à faire preuve
de bienveillance entre eux ici et
marie-eve cousineau radio canada québec